heute bist du eine berühmte professorin
du hast dich zurecht gemacht neuer
designeranzug neue lackschuhe in 15
minuten beginnt deine vorlesung auf dem
weg zum vorlesungssaal kommst du an
einem teich vorbei doch was ist das
ohne zu überlegen springst du in den
teich und rettet das kind anzug und
schuhe sind ruiniert
die vorlesung ist im eimer
doch hier ist vollkommen klar du hast
das einzig richtige getan
das leben des kindes wiegten am zug die
schuhe und eine erfolgreiche vorlese und
bei weitem auf nach deiner
rettungsaktion kommst du nach hause und
findet den briefkasten post von einer
entwicklungsorganisation sie ruft dazu
auf für die hungernden kinder in nigeria
zu spenden
mit 10 franken sicherste die ernährung
eines kindes für einen ganzen monat
ansonsten würde der junge sterben
spendet du
wenn nicht weshalb springst du in den
teich und opfers teure markenkleider für
das leben eines kindes spende ist aber
keine zehn franken für ein kind in
afrika
das ist doch nicht das gleiche sagst du
warum eigentlich nicht
sind die afrikanischen kinder vielleicht
zu weit weg nehmen wir an ein freund von
dir ist mit seinem sohn in afrika auf
safari
sein sohn wird lebensbedrohlich verletzt
und ein freund bittet dich sofort geld
zu überweisen damit das kind im
krankenhaus vor ort behandelt werden
kann würde das geld locker machen
stimmt's geografische distanz macht also
keinen unterschied oder spendet du
vielleicht nicht weil du unsicher bist
ob dein geld das hungernde kind wirklich
erreicht und nicht den falschen zugute
kommt wenn du geld schickst für das kind
eines freundes weißt du allerdings auch
nicht ob es unterwegs korrupten behörden
in die hände fällt
aber weißt du deshalb kein geld an
deinen freund für dich ist klar das
ertrinkende kind musst du retten musst
du auch spenden